[Music]
there's nothing out there like it no
nothing I'm a new friend real or
imaginary imagine it's the film about a
boy who knows how long he's gonna live I
was told you know by these dreams that
he's gotten a certain amount of time and
it's just about the people that he
affects in the lives that he changes you
know I guess in a really broad general
and then you you throw some time travel
in there and some bunnies and and you've
got Donnie Darko I guess I felt like it
was an interesting story about growing
up you know that that it was a different
turn on it a different manifestation of
it but at least it was the sort of anti
teen movie there was a time in all these
movies about coming into adulthood or
whatever that might that period of time
your life might be we're about like you
know parties and sticking things into
pies and that was a movie that was sort
of more about the psychological journey
of like of adolescence and the confusion
of all of it absolutely so I think that
kind of resonates it in a different way
and has and it's sort of this I've seen
it's a rite of passage in one way or
another a certain point different
people's lives are like oh I remember
watch now yeah you know what and that
was that's what it was for me
you know we're cop
I remember Patrick Swayze having an
electric scooter driving back and forth
from sadness electric scooter and I um
yeah and he was like he was just such a
lovely man and just filled with so much
kindness and love and like and I
remember being really young and being so
supportive in kind and then I have this
really crazy picture I took of him on
his electric scooter that just he just
looks like this sort of wonderful madman
and I loved it and he was I just I
remember Patrick in particular on that
set
you